نجمات التفوق الجوي الروسي كما وصفنا
لمعنى بمقدمه الاسلحه التي تعتمد عليها
موسكو لمواجهه هدايا الغرب العسكريه
المقدمه لكيف هذه الطائرات تتصدرها مروحيه
او التمساح الروسي والتي تصنف من بين افضل
طائرات الهليكوبتر الهجوميه في العالم هذه
المروحيه التي تحلق بسرعه 300 كم في
الساعه تتميز بقدرتها على العمل بظروف
جويه مختلفه هي تجمع بين وظائف المروحيه
الهجوميه ومركبه الاستطلاع ومركز قياده
قادر على الاتصال والتنسيق بين الطائرات
وحتى المحطات الارضيه تم تجهيزها بنظام
دفاع حديث محمول جوا يوفر تلقائيا لحمايه
ضد الصواريخ ذات الرؤوس الموجهه بالاشعه
تحت الحمراء تتمتع بقدره على المناوره
بفضل التصميم المحوري للشفرات الرئيسيه
وتعد المروحيه الوحيده في العالم المز
بنظام طرد لانقاذ الطاقم غير ان سيده الجو
الجديده الاوفى في قائمه موسكو حتى اللحظه
هي مسيره
او صائده المدرعات التي طورتها شركه تو
كلاشنكوف هي تعد هذه المسيره لغما جويا
قاسيا يسيطر على السماء بسرعه تصل الى 300
كيلو متر في الساعه ومدى يصل الى 40
كيلومترا وتوصف بالخدومه بسبب استخدامها
في مهام الاستطلاع والهجوم وتحمل رؤوسا
شديده الانفجار او الانشطار تصل الى ثلاثه
كيلوغرامات الدقه من مميزاتها كذلك فمسيره
زال لانسيت تتمتع بتوجيه بصري وتلفزيوني
يمكنها من التحكم في توجيه ذخيره حتى في
المراحل النهائيه قبل الصياد الهدف مراوغه
تستطيع قنص اهدافها اثناء الطيران وتباغت
العدو بسبب قله الضوضاء التي يسببها
محركها الكهربائي ما يعزز من عنصر
المفاجاه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات